they they are clear as day traveling in
packs driving like Bandits around here a
teen prank gone way wrong when it was
sconsin high school principal admits to
tackling a boy while he tried to teepee
the man's house I got the one kid then
he picked me up from my neck and he
started like strangling me and then he
started dragging me the incident
happened on September 21st last year in
Williams Bay Wisconsin it's about an
hour Southwest of walk that's where
Brent manky is caught on body camera
video angrily approaching an officer
apparently this wasn't his first time
getting
pranked year in a row manky a high
school principal in Whitewater about 35
minutes north of Williams Bay tells the
responding officer that teenagers are
running wild in his neighborhood and
these kids are running rans sacking
through this neighborhood okay they're
running away jumping over neighbor
fences into the pool they're ransacking
my house for the third year in a row and
I apologize for losing my cool mansky
explains he has kids at home who are
scared after multiple years of pranks
but I've got two little kids that I've
got to try to explain this to in the
first year with the ketchup and the
ranch was one thing then with the beer
can breaking my sighing was the next
thing but this time it wasn't ketchup or
beer bottles but a single roll of toilet
paper thrown on tansky's lawn he
explains to this officer saying he got
one kid what happened tonight tonight
they were doing the rans sacking of
running around and when they came upon
my property started CH chucking the
toilet paper up in my yard okay I got
the one kid okay what do you mean got
the one kid I got his hoodie from him
okay um and then they all Escape through
that way okay manky doesn't yet admit to
tackling the boy and instead complains
about the lack of police on patrol I am
so beyond pissed I had two traffic stops
in less than 3 minutes I got a couple
people ided but say they weren't
involved I know um I are they wearing
black I well I chased a group of kids in
Black all night long yeah um there was
another group that was in here prior to
the night and I actually parked just
around here and was spent a good amount
saw a good amount of time up in in the
trees and yep made some contacts with
people that apparently had permission
but at least know what groups were with
what groups manky says he's been
tracking the kids who've been circling
his home
four boys two cars and then they
proceeded to circle around here looking
to see if they could get me to come back
out okay and then they're parking over
here and they're running through
people's freaking yards and I mean I am
sick and tired of this there's no
question manky is enraged as the body
camera recording goes on he continues
swearing while saying he will track down
the perpetrators at their school there's
two people on duty on the night
everybody in this town knows these kids
are running through run I mean my issue
is more with Chief Tim my issue is more
with with Dr White like what oh sorry
sorry that happened well no Dr White you
don't live here and you don't have your
house getting destroyed No it's h tough
luck okay I've had it
okay and I and I want this kid ID on
camera at school because it's a very
distinctive Patagonia I I I am 90% sure
I know who it is okay who would you
presume it be and we can narrow down
then from
the okay all right um it I obviously you
understand how the school works and we
can or knowing his classroom schedule
and so on and so forth you can just kind
of build a timeline off of that yep okay
um excellent Patagonia what size are you
you holding on to this or yes I'm
holding out this and I'm bringing in all
the the the toilet paper and I'm going
to throw it on Dr White's desk and say
this is the third time I've talked to
you about this manky goes on saying he
watched the kids go from house to house
in the neighborhood but didn't catch it
on cam did you get you have cameras
correct did you get anything on your I
turned them off so I could so they
didn't get activated when these old came
rolling through they were in here no
liutenant for 25 minutes I watched them
go from the Welsh I watched them go to
the Nickels I watched them go around and
around and around and around okay the
fact that there's only two of you guys
on duty tonight is utterly ridiculous
okay it is the only night they're out
rans sacking it's the only one right it
it just it makes absolutely no sense and
his frustration doesn't stop there they
they are clear as day traveling in packs
driving like Bandits around here and
then turning their lights off when they
get to the place they want to go but
there's only two of you how the hell are
you guys supposed to do all
this I mean it it just makes no sense it
makes absolutely no sense to me okay and
I don't know what the other officer's
name is I don't think I've ever met her
but like you don't have you don't have a
chance you don't have a
chance I mean it's me that's had to
spend $500 on cameras it's me that had
to spend $400 on the side it's me that
had to spend a day power washing to get
all the off my
house that's the frustrating part High
spe
chases unruly suspects I will kill that
mother CH me no do it stay in the I like
dramatic DUI I'mma pass everything that
she trying to do and shocking body cam
footage hey get on the ground get on the
ground law on crime presents body cam
the place for real raw and wild police
videos you should have seen it it was
good it's on body camera I'll show it to
you catch the action and subscribe to
our new YouTube channel
now a second body camera recording shows
the officer returned to man's home hours
later I'm getting scared of now okay
okay they just came circling this thing
three times and then they stopped over
here and then they were looking for one
of these little dropped something maybe
they found it maybe they didn't oh you
so they like came back to grab it type
deal but it was not the same I could be
wrong but it was not not appear to be
the same vehicle before making another
comment about the kids I mean they have
no regard for anything anymore manky
finally admits he tackled one of them I
tackled right here you tackled the kid
here yeah that's how I got a sweatshir
the responding officer then finds one of
the boys cell phones near man's house oh
here it is so that's what we're looking
for so can you tell me
how perfect oh I got it I'll take it I'm
pressing charges I I I
am so they're going to be coming back
looking for it again manky again says
he's scared for his children a bunch of
the kids had these on at the Powderpuff
game that and that's going to be my
issue with Dr White what in and I excuse
my like I'm scared for myself for my my
kids M like how do you explain to a
seven-year-old dad why are they throwing
beer cans at our house shattering
sighting dad why are they spraying
ketchup and Ranch you don't even work
there hours later the police have
tracked down some of the kids involved
this is body camera video of their
interview taken at school the day after
the tee incident I just want you to be
honest with me and tell me why you're
here cuz I already know why you're here
and we had this conversation last year
yeah and so honest
was much appreciated yeah so it was it
the boy whose name has been withheld
from audio explains he and a few others
were out teeing the night before and
what what did you guys do we just like T
everybody else was and before like the
night end we just like went to the last
neighborhood and we just like Mo on
around throwing toilet paper and then
like came up by a house and we we we
didn't even like step on property we
just we threw two rolls didn't even
stick they fell right through the tree
so at what
property think manies yeah yeah okay and
what happened continue and then and then
obviously we ran obviously cuz see what
I supposed to do soon the boy explains
how manky physically attacked him he he
ran after me and then he tackled me and
then he like got he like took his
fingers dug it into my eyes like way
more aggressively than he really should
have the boy continues saying he has
marks on his neck from the altercation
you have any marks on your eyes right
here on your neck you set your eyes I
know but then he picked me up from my
neck and he started like strangling me
and then he started dragging me and then
I just like I just like obviously like
cuz whatever so I just slipped out of my
head my my my hoodie and my um ski mask
and I just ran the boy admits it was his
phone that got lost along man's yard did
you lose anything else I pH in the same
location I really don't know same
incident you believe I mean I think so
okay cuz I don't know well your your
phone was found right there he then
explains what happened the night before
saying he had no idea man's house was
off limits he was like we're just going
to get houses that we got permiss
permissed from M so I was with them for
like mainly then you I just like did and
then you
and finished off and did was manky the
only one you didn't have permission to
do
yeah yeah or are there other ones that
are out there you see you seem like you
seem like there's other random trees we
just we just F trees we we were we were
there wasn't specific houses we were
aiming for we were just doing like the
neighborhood just like trees okay there
not like we weren't we weren't targeting
people right we were just doing other
than manky not really but sure cuz you
know where he lives and you were told
last year to stay away from it I mean
not really this year we never we we this
year we didn't get told that we couldn't
TV yeah it was on princial Su Johnson's
presentation I can have you can ask
anyone no one no one no one heard that
no I mean at least I didn't okay well it
was on her presentation so you must have
missed that part later the officer
speaks with another boy involved and we
gone like just around the area too to
like our friend's house and we're
getting their house and we were by it
and I I don't even know how much is even
like on there if it's even like if
anything even got on it or even on a
tree or anything but um D toss like one
roll like didn't even go anywhere
literally just like tossed it out in the
yard and he I don't know that's like
right as like Mr he just like well
obious he's probably like waiting for us
there like it was going to happen and
then he just like ran out of his house
this boy goes to the Whiteboard to map
out what happened explaining when manky
tackled his friend okay there's like a
little like tree here okay we were like
just walking like up around here and we
just like toss one he just like sitting
right there and and this is little like
little front door and then this door
there he came like right out of there
the second he even like tossed one and
then just like I don't if he like chased
us or what it was he just ran like right
right at us the second we um even toss
one over we were still on the side of
the road like this is okay we were still
like right here and then what happened
after that well I don't know if he like
had said something I couldn't really
hear or if he like swar us or said like
something like I I got you guys or like
I got you like effers or whatever he
says he ran off right away gone I just I
ran I was like I'm not going to and it's
not even the fact that like I was more
like didn't want to get caught by him I
just like didn't know if he was like
angry or like what what was going to
happen so I mean that's was kind of an
instinct too is just to like out there
and then this is all the corn field I
just kind of ran right in the middle of
just wait kind of hung out and sat there
till and then you
guys over here yeah we went way over
there literally had thrown a roll and it
got to here and I went to go over pick
it up cuz then we we actually were just
like it's not even working like why
don't we just like go or like it's
pointless it's so late cuz we check the
time where like it was way too late to
be out so I was like okay we we got to
go somewhere so then I went to go grab
it and that was right as he ran out like
I was like right here he was right here
it it's probably around there so I just
and where it um I think did you both go
over to grab
it yeah well I think he was like right
here like right next to me cuz I
obviously didn't get caught by him um
and like way behind me in this little
like ditch like there's like a little
dip or whatever so then I was out and
then I looked back and I saw got caught
like right away and I I was like I'm I'm
get out of here the boys faced
trespassing and vandalism citations but
manky was not charged because
prosecutors said they couldn't prove the
attack happened without Reasonable Doubt
reporting for long crime I'm Sierra
Gillespie